27,5 millions d'euros c'est le budget
annuel de rimage le fond culturel du
Conseil de l'Europe un budget abondé par
37 des États membres du Conseil de
l'Europe qui permet de soutenir chaque
année une centaine de production écoutez
Catherine trottman la présidente de
l'image et aujourd'hui nous contribuons
à soutenir des films qui sont
respectueux des valeurs du Conseil de
l'Europe liberté d'expression pas de
racisme pas de violence pas d'appel à la
haine bien entendu donc ces 27,5
millions contribuent à financer des
films qui ont déjà
un certain seuil je dirais de
financement acquis et qui vient
compléter et donne en quelque sorte un
label de qualité qui est celui de rimage
depuis 10 ans et rimage promeut
également l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes dans les métiers du cinéma le
fond culturel incite par exemple les
femmes à déposer des projets en leur
attribuant en cas de sélection
l'entièreté de la somme qu'elle demande
c'est aussi mixité des équipes qui
regardaient et par ce mécanisme là nous
favorisons l'accès au financement des
femmes car on avait constaté qu'elle
demandait moins d'argent que les hommes
et que du coup elles étaient toujours un
peu moins bien lotis donc l'égalité
commençait aussi par la même
reconnaissance en termes de qualité et
la même reconnaissance en termes d'accès
si vous voulez ou financement désormais
aux images j'aimerais que parmi tous les
projets soutenus la moitié soit déposée
par des femmes c'est efficace parce que
nous avons aussi eu nous avons soutenu
des premiers films de femmes de jeunes
femmes et ses premiers films ont eu des
succès dans les festivals et dans les
salles et donc ça aussi quand je parlais
de confiance une de ces réalisatrices
m'a dit avoir le label de rimage et
pouvoir discuter avec les gens de rimage
pour moi c'est le trouver le courage
d'aller au bout de mon projet et ça pour
nous ça n'a pas de prix c'est à dire que
ça permet aussi à des jeunes femmes de
se lancer et parfois rencontrer le
succès d'être exemplaire
10 films de la 76e édition du Festival
de Cannes ont été soutenus par leur
image l'occasion de gagner en visibilité
et de continuer à montrer son utilité
pour le cinéma européen